ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد الجدل لم يتوقف
منذ انتقال ملكيه تويتر الى رجل الاعمال
ماستر تطورات كان اخرها انا المنصه اخبرت
موظفيها بان مباني مكاتب الشركات تغلق
مؤقتا وبا ان هذا القرار سيسري على الفوره
وفي رساله ابلغت الشركه الموظفين بان
المكاتب ستفتح يوم 21 من نوفمبر دون ان
تذكر سببا لهذه الخطوه ياتي هذا الاعلان
وسطا تقارير عن استقاله اعداد كبيره من
الموظفين بعد ان طالبهم الى الماسك بالعمل
لسعه الطويله وبكثافه عاليه او مغادره
الشركه وقالت الشركه في رساله يرجى
الاستمرار في الامتثال لسياسه الشركه
بالامتناع عن مناقشه المعلومات الشركه
السريه على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي او
الصحافه او اي مكان اخر وفي رساله بالبريد
الالكتروني الى الموظفين قال ماسك انه يجب
على الموظفين فقط على التعهد اذا كان
يريدون البقاء او الحصول على مكافات نهايه
الخدمه لمده ثلاثه اشهر وفي وقت سابق لا
تشركه انها ستخفض قوتها العامله بنسبه تصل
الى 50% اعلنوا الشركه عن اغلاني عن اغلاق
ما كاتبها جاء بشكل مؤقت وسط اشارات على
ان عددا كبيره من الموظفين قد استقالوا
لانهم لم يقبلوا شروط ماسك الجديده وينشر
المضافون تغريدات على هاشتاق احب مكان او
احب مكان عملك مع رامز تعبري للتحيه
لاظهار انهم يغدرون الشركه في ما نشر مصر
تغريده قال فيها افضل الناس مستمره لذلك
انا لست قلقا للغايه
[موسيقى]
هناك هذا الموضوع مع ضيفنا ونحاول فهمها
مع ضيفنا من الرياض لؤي بن موسى مستشار
حوكمات الشركات اهلا بك معنا سيد لؤي الى
هذا الملف لفهم في الواقع هذه التصرفاتي
الى الماس يعني اليوم يتحدث ملك تويتر
الجديد بامكانيه فصله ل 50% من العاملين
في هذه الشركه هكذا تحرك هل يمكن ان يفيد
الشركه فعلا كما يقول ماسك او يمكن ان
يعطلها ان يلغيها تماما هناك مخاوف حتى من
ان هذه الشركه قد تكون مستقبلا شيء من
الماضي
مساء الخير
مشاهدين 50 50% اذا كان في خطه استراتيجيه
واضحه لحد الان ماسك ما اعلن عن اي خطه
واضحه للمساهمين بحكم انه الان اصبح هو
المالك الرئيس للشركه
ويعني السلطه المطلقه مفسده مطلقه
الرجل يعني اتخذ قرارات اداريه بحكم يعني
رؤيه الشخصيه هو يجد انه ااه انها صحيحه
ولكن واقع الحال هي فوضى اداريه مسببه
بلبله
واصبحت همم يعني تشكك همم في مدى قابليه
تويتر همم للاستدامه والنمو المستقبلي
تويتر همم حظي بدعم وهمم يعني همم ثقه
الجهات حتى الحكوميه على مختلف دول العالم
وهناك حسابات حكوميه موثقه همم تنشر
اخبارها الان مع اختلاف ساره والتغيرات
المفاجئه
وال عدم الوضوح والضبابيه انا ما اعرف
حقيقه هل هذا الامر راح يستمر ام اا هذه
الحسابات راح يعني يتم اغلاقها وانهائها
لانه اصبح خطر مهدد حقيقه بعدم وجود اي
وضوح حتى على مستوى الامن الامن
الاستبراني وامن المعلومات
عنها ولكن تتحدث همم سيد لؤي عن سلطه ماسك
المطلقه فيما في ما قبل تتذكر قبل او مع
الاعلان عن هذه الصفقه كنا نتحدث عن ان
سلطته ستكون محدده بما ان هناك مجلس اداره
كيف تمكن الى الماس من السيطره بكل هذه
القوه على همم
همم كل القرارات التي يمكن ان تتخذ داخل
الشركه
همم التشريعات ضبطت واحددته وجود وجود
وجود همم سلطه اداريه ولكن اللي حصل واللي
شفناه غير ذلك تماما
الغائه لمجلس الاداره الغاءه لاعاده كبير
من همم من همم
الشواغر الوظيفيه اللي راح يوظف عليها او
الموظفين الحاليين يعني همم وضح لجميع
المستخدمين والجميع المستفيدين وصحاب
المصلحه في تويتر انه الاداره الجديده هي
اداره عشوائيه ما لها اي تنظيم ولا لها اي
اعتداء همم لو اخذتي هذا الموضوع للمنظور
حوما قواعد الحكم ثلاثه اهمها للسدامه انك
تضمن اجراءاتك يكون نهايتها مستدامه على
مستوى المنشاه انا اشك في هذا الامر خصوصا
بانه الاجراءات جالسه تطلع من دون اي همم
تنسيق اي خطه اليوم كانت 20 دولار همم
قيمه التوثيق فجاه
100 دولار ما نعرف بكره كيف هتكون فهذه
هذه الفوضى الاداريه سببها قرارات شخص
واحد اعتقد انه من الضروري تدخل كبار
الملاك
بالاجتماعيه
يعني هذا سببها سببها هو السلطه المطلقه
للون ماسك ولكن البعض يتخوف من التداعيات
هل يمكن حل الشركه
بسبب وجود الميناء الماليه القويه لها
والملاكها انا ما اعتقد هذا الشيء ولكن قد
تكون تداعياتها اذا اذا يعني صحه العباره
تداعيتها الامنيه اعلى من تداعيات
الاقتصاديه الان موجود شخص يمتلك هذه
المنصه القويه وهمم وجود هذه الحسابات
اللي ممكن يتم اختراقها بطريقه معينه بسبب
عدم وجود همم الفريق اللي تم فصله
والكوادر اللي كانت موجوده في السابق هذا
هذا خطر امني هذا خطر امني كبير جدا همم
في نشر اشاعات في نشر معلومات مظله في نشر
ايضا من المعلومات ومنصه هذه تعتبر من من
اقوى منصات الحاليه الموجوده واعتقد لاحقا
راح يكون في بديل عنها احتمال يكون الصين
احتمال يكون من الخليج منطقه الخليج من
خلال احد همم يعني الصناديق المستثمرين
الجهات اللي حابه انها تحل محل هذه المنصه
قد يكون همم ثقه تويتر بمدى امكانيه
استمرارها يعتمد على شغله
بقاء الحسابات الحكوميه بقاء عدد بسيط من
رواد من مشاهير التواصل الاجتماعي
والامر الثالث وهو الاهم همم
كبار الملاك الموجودين حاليا في الشركات
دقيقه ونص تقريبا من فصل كل هؤلاء
العاملين وهم يحملون كما قلت همم انت منذ
قليل يحملون بعض المعلومات لا يمكن ان لا
تؤثر عليه نحن افراد طبيعيه ولكن هناك همم
اصحاب همم
حسابات لديهم مناصب حساسه
بلا شك ولا ولا اشك في يعني بانه راح يتم
استجواب ماسك في الكونجرس او في جلسه
السجون معينه مثل ما صار مع ذكر بيرك في
فيسبوك قريبا اذا الامر يعني تداعى واصبح
خارج عن السيطره معلومات
حساسه البيانات الامنيه للاشخاص برضه كذلك
حساسه همم
وقد نتاثر في حال لم يتم ضبط ذلك اداريا
بشكل عاجل جدا من ضمن
يعني الخطه اللي راح يشتغل عليها
مره عليك او قرات قبل على
رئيس شركه بهذه الطريقه في اخذه للقرارات
اعتقد بانه الشخصيه استثنائيه صح ايه
هذه شخصيه استثنائيه وان شاء الله انها ما
تكون موجوده
الرياض شكرا جزيلا لك
ولا نقاش دائما بقيه اعود القاكم غدا في
نفس التوقيت السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]